[Music]
and one of the challenges that we've
seen
time and time again is that there's
often a gap
between data scientists and those
stakeholders they're hoping to inform
and that gap a lot of times is the
result of different mediums
and so that creates a problem for us is
that if we just wait for decision makers
to
proactively go visit our work we're not
actually closing that gap
but that's one problem we also see
something else kind of interesting
happen
as data science teams try to close this
gap
and so one one thing as we said is that
maybe the dashboards fall by the wayside
another thing that can often happen is
that stakeholders
will get excited they'll say great this
insight makes sense
can you bring it to my medium you know
can you
copy and paste those predictions into my
spreadsheet
or can you send me a screenshot of that
plot
so i can put it in my presentation and
that leads to a lot of
painful labor-intensive work but
i'd like to propose for you today an
alternative
a solution that we've found a lot of
success using ourselves here at rstudio
and so what does this solution entail
instead of creating a dashboard what we
like to do is create
a proactive notifier or something that
is going to
alert me to the information that i need
to know
and in our case you know we spend most
of our time inside of our inboxes so
that's where our alerts goes is through
email
and so so that's what we're going to
talk about today is how you can use a
rich set of our packages
to allow you to create these proactive
notifications
oftentimes these notifications need to
meet the expectations of our
stakeholders for how they're formatted
so we'll look at some new packages that
are available
to help you precisely format these
results and then finally we don't want
to solve
this dashboard fatigue problem by
introducing another type of fatigue
which would be email
you know fatigue and so we're going to
talk about how you can only send these
alerts
on conditions so that instead of sending
emails
every day can send emails more
specifically when there's a problem at
hand
we also don't want to introduce data
science fatigue so we're going to talk
about how we can
achieve these proactive notifications in
an automated way
the picture that you're seeing here is
one of my favorite examples of this
workflow
one of my roles at our studio is to keep
track of all the different r
packages that we build and maintain for
some of you on the line our packages
might be a newer thing so
briefly they're sort of the bread and
butter of how data science gets done in
r
they're also one of the main things that
we're responsible for at our studio is
creating these different r packages
and so every day we go and we build all
of these packages
and we want to know if that any of those
builds fail
especially if it's a really popular
package we don't want
uh to get a whole bunch of emails from
users saying hey this package isn't
available or doesn't work
we kind of want to stay ahead of those
types of problems and so what a data
scientist named greg and i came up with
is this workflow where every day we run
these builds
and then if there's a problem and
critically only if there's a problem
do we get these types of targeted emails
that tell me exactly what the problem
was
and allow me to then take further action
we're not the only ones who are kind of
using this pattern
successfully so just want to tell you a
few quick stories before we get into the
weeds of writing the code
one of my favorite stories is from a
large infrastructure as a service
provider
so a company that maintains thousands if
not hundreds of thousands of servers
and what they use this workflow to do
was
track their hardware uptime and then if
they saw a problem arising
they could send a proactive alert out to
their vendors
in the context of their support level
agreement or sla
and what this team was really excited
about is before adopting this workflow
they had done this type of task in jira
and any time they onboarded a new vendor
or they modified
their sla they had to manually click
through a whole bunch of steps in jira
to accomplish the you know this task
the great thing about this workflow is
that it's all based on code so
it's really easy to reuse you know these
different rules and different
markdown documents that you're going to
write and so this allowed the team to
easily
cut down their onboarding time another
uh
really awesome story of this type of
technology applied
was in a high-tech manufacturer
people-ops department so kind of an hr
group
and they had this challenging task where
they needed to notify division managers
about employee overtime problems so
you know say an employee worked more
over time than they were allowed they
wanted to send out an alert
now before they had a dashboard and what
they found
was their 30 different division managers
were not reliably going to that
dashboard every day to
check if there was problems and so they
adopted this workflow to instead
send out an email to a manager only if
there was actually a problem with a
specific employee's overtime submission
and they actually won an award of
excellence for you know adopting this
workflow
which i think is is really exciting
because it's ultimately a pretty simple
concept that we're talking about here
and so if they're able to win excellence
awards i think that's going to be
accessible to a lot
of teams as well
so this is our main document our main
report in connect
so it looks great we actually have a
history of these documents they'll be
published every day
but to do that you have to set up you
actually have to
go to schedule and then schedule this
output
to be run every day so it'll take all
your code it'll run every day
maybe on different data that's kind of
the hope because what happens is
you'll be connected to a different data
source well the same data source will be
updated every single day
so we'll get different data and possibly
different alerts so in this day we did
have
a few problems that are aligned here in
red
so that's great but we have to check
this every day
to see that there's a problem right when
we send email
we can send it when there's a problem
and we don't have to be checking this is
almost the same problem as the dashboard
having a report here but the email sort
of like solves that problem
so to schedule that we sales really
every day and the key thing is to send
an email after update
and then we set some recipients
it could be sean for instance here
oh sorry we have to go here first
and have him be as part of the
yeah on the list
great now we can save that and now we
have a master list of people that can
view our changes document and we can
schedule
uh connect to send emails to those
recipients through here
so i'll just do this one more time this
is kind of cool
great and we'll see this brilliant so
every day
it's going to be run and we can change
this of course but this is a daily data
so it makes sense to send it every day
and it will send an email only if the
the thresholds were exceeded
and we can actually preview the email
send one to us yourself
just to you know sort of like um debug
the email and make sure it looks good
before it actually goes out
for legos production so i can send this
and i actually happen to have one open
so it shows it to me
right here this is my email client
so we can see that the subject here is
one of our kpis
and parentheses three that's the glue
work that we did here total exceed
uh broke thresholds and we have the list
of things here which is great because
if you look at this in your list of
messages you see this right away before
even opening up the email
and the body looks really good this
actually looks really wonderful on a
small device because the text is quite
large
we have just the important things which
are the table a little bit of text
just to sort of show what's being shown
and importantly here's the attachment
[Music]
you